Over the last year or so, I've been telling
you about this shift that we have seen in,
um,
on the youtube algorithm towards what they
describe as authoritative, um, sources and
what they also described as a move against
promoting conspiracy type content.
And we had already noticed pretty early on
that we were immediately losing huge numbers
of views to the tune of millions of views
per month from Youtube, uh, recommendations
algorithm immediately after youtube made this
announcement many months ago.
And we now have some data thanks to mark Ledwidge
who has been following and gathering a lot
of this information and, and writing about
it, uh, that shows that everything that is
happening is exactly and I mean exactly as
we predicted and it's not that we had any
special insight, it was just if you paid attention
to the combination of what youtube was saying
and what was happening to our channel, it
was very clear what it was that was going
to happen.
So what we have to determine at this point
is whether shows like the David Pakman show
are reasonable collateral damage that we just
have to accept because we want youtube to
be cautious about this conspiracy content.
Like are we just reasonably getting hurt as
an aside or is this unacceptable in terms
of collateral damage that is being suffered
by non conspiracy, uh, independent media.
So first there's no question marks.
Research finds that the deep state sort of
conspiracy channels are being hurt by youtube
shifts, which is the goal.
And as mark writes recommendations, the deep
state conspiracy channels like next news network
have drastically reduced.
If you look at the number of recommendations
to a long list of conspiracy channels, um,
they are down exactly as Youtube said that
they wanted to do.
So in that sense, youtube has succeeded at
what they publicly stated they wanted to do.
There has not been a change, interestingly
enough with regard to the sort of left right
center political balance of the recommendations.
And this is once again, I said from the beginning
when I was on the Genre Joe Rogan program,
when I was talking to, you know, Tim Poole,
whoever else, I saw no evidence that what
youtube was doing had a, uh, an inherent political
bias that uh, whether you are left right or
center, what was happening was youtube was
starting to prioritize legacy corporate content
over independent content.
And to the extent that independent content
outside of the conspiracy genre can be left
right or center, I saw no political bias in
what was going on.
And indeed, Mark's research finds the same
thing.
Uh, and again, when you look at the balance
of who is winning as a result of this, exactly
as we started seeing at the very beginning,
the winners are corporate media check out.
So one question, a reasonable question is
if youtube is recommending these conspiracy
channels less and less, what happens when
you go and watch videos on those channels?
What is it that youtube recommends to you
instead?
And as an example, they are recommending a
lot more Fox News.
So this is a comparison of before and after
recommendations from the conspiracy channels
to Fox News.
What you see is that instead of recommending
other conspiracy channels when you're already
watching one of the conspiracy channels, youtube
is recommending Fox News significantly more.
My guess is that it would be the same with
CNN and MSNBC, etc.
Is this better?
I mean, I guess it's slightly better, right?
Certainly this is a huge corporate handout.
Would we rather someone who's in the conspiracy
rabbit hole on Youtube get recommended more
conspiracy rabbit hole videos or a clip on
MSNBC?
I mean, I don't know.
It's very, very, uh, sort of hypothetical.
Uh, but this is the big picture result, uh,
that is hurting us.
I've been talking about this for a year, almost
since the beginning.
This is how we collaterally get crushed in
the move away from quote, conspiracy channels
and towards authoritative sources.
What happens is we get swept up along with
many other channels like ours.
And Mark Actually mentions us saying, quote,
this is bad news for many youtube creators
like David Pakman, a politically progressive
talk show host that is careful about the quality
of information in his show.
These changes have increased recommendations
towards hyper-partisan channels like Fox and
MSNBC who regularly misrepresent current events
and promote conspiracy theories.
I don't know the, I dunno if he's making a
complete equivalency there between Fox and
MSNBC in the conspiracies they promote.
But, uh, in any case, mark goes on to write,
I liked David Pacman's response to algorithmic
adversity.
He is diversifying his distribution to twitch
and obtaining a stream of income directly
from supporters through his website.
This makes him less exposed to the algorithmic
gods as youtube has decided to make their
platform more pleasing to corporate media
and advertisers.
Creators need to move or diversify between
platforms and create leverage and then may
be most devastatingly.
Here's the data for specific winners and losers
from all of this.
Our channel is one of the most negatively
affected in terms of recommendations from
these algorithmic changes, so the solutions
are sadly not glamorous, but they are clear
and known to us.
It's just support the shows you like directly.
Here is an independent person.
It's not me telling you this, it's his research
and what is what is clearly the result of
of what has been done on the Youtube Algorithm
is that it's crushing us, so support us directly.
If you like what we're doing, that's the way
and support whatever show you like.
If there's other shows you like more than
this one and you say, I've got five bucks
a month to contribute, I'm going to go to
them instead of David Pakman do it with us.
You go to our website, join pacman.com you
pick up a membership.
It's really easy.
We're talking about six bucks a month or 60
for the year.
If that's too high, no problem.
Use the coupon code.
This is 2020 and you'll save 40%.
You can also go to patrion.com/david Pakman
show, ah, throw us a dollar or two a month.
That's all we're talking about and it really
makes a big difference and I think that at
this point it's pretty clear that this is
a unfortunately here to stay.